hello YouTube just lower some offense
this is grunge in here welcome to the
ninth part of the dirty tricks
if you are bored with playing your
regular opening and if you're looking
for a new weapon which you can
occasionally employed in quick games
especially at online chess servers or a
friendly match then grubs attack is the
right choice for you this opening will
phone your opponent to their own
resources it contains lots of tricks
where your opponent needs to play very
accurately to defuse all of them the
analysis which I am going to present in
this video are not published anywhere as
all the work has been done by me with
the help of frits engine so in other
words I'm sharing one of my own secrets
with you the opening start with a weird
move that is the move G fool and black
player will definitely think what's this
isn't that I'm going to play the move
defy grabbing the center and attacking
the g4
well yep that's true but imagine the
second surprise with the move Bishop to
g2 which looks completely stupid because
it's attacking the d5 pawn which is
formally defended by the Queen and that
means if black wants black can easily
capture the g4 pawn well if you open
play the other moves for example ePHI or
c6 then you play the move sv and
continue with an equal game but there
are more than seventy percent chances
that your opponent is definitely going
to grab the g4 pawn and wondering what's
going on well here's the answer the fun
start with the MU c4
now as I have highlighted over here
black has few choices but the first
point to be notice is if black captured
the c4 porn then that comes Bishop
captures b7 and after Knight to d7
Bishop captures rook and after Queen
captures Bishop and the MU f3
objectively speaking your computer is
saying that the position is equal but
practical point of view if you play
accurately that extra exchange will
definitely count so that is the reason
why Black has tried other moves over
here the first more I want to consider
is the movie six after this move I'm
going to propose what should play the
move Queen to b3 so attacking the b7
pawn as well as attacking the defy form
accordingly Black has tried few
responses the first response I want to
cover is the move Queen to see it after
this move why should capture the d5 pawn
and now believe it or not the best move
here is the move c6 the nature looking
move that is e captures V Phi we leads
to the instant disaster after the move
Bishop captures d5
so white is now looking at too soft spot
of the black cam that is the f7 and b7
which black cannot defend both of them
so for example if black tried to save
the b7 pawn with the move c6 then there
comes Bishop captures f7 and after King
to d8 not only white will gain a piece
just in the opening but black king is
clearly misplaced
the second move Knight to f6 doesn't
change the scenario because after this
what is going to capture the e6 pawn and
how where black responded the game is
simply lost for example if your opponent
plays the move Bishop captures e6 then
you can simply capture the b7 pawn with
the Queen and this time around white
will grab the rook in the corner so
let's see the best move in this position
that is c6 after the move c6
why should continue with the forcing
move that is h3
now black response is pretty much forced
over here black cannot play the move
Bishop to h5 because what is going to
capture the e6 pawn and when black can
recapture with the F pawn the black
queen it looks like doing a baby sitting
on the c8 so that cannot be good right
so that's why Bishop to a5 is forced at
this position after the move Bishop to
fr once again we are going to play a
forcing move that is Knight to c3 and
now black response is forced
if black carelessly develop a king side
piece for example Knight to f6 then
there comes he for attacking the bishop
and after Bishop to g3 we have familiar
babysitting scenario
so that's why
at this position black has to accept the
pawn now the most obvious looking move
is he captures d5 after this White has
the another stunner that is Knight
captures d5 BAM
the first point to be notice is if black
captured this night then white will
recapture with the bishop and now once
again familiar trick is on the table
which we have already covered in the
early section when first time I seen
this movie I thought that isn't that a
blunder because black can obviously
played the move Bishop to e6 and never
piece well this is exactly white once
because now white plays the move Queen
to e4 tactics based on the pin so black
is desperate to get a piece then he has
to continue with the movie file and we
are continuously creating a pin with the
move Queen to c2 I reach the scene I own
one of my game where my opponent
responded with the move Knight to a6
side a is very simple black wants to
protect the Queen now and now black is
all set to capture the piece now instead
of 96 if my opponent has played the move
Knight to d7 then Knight to f4 is a very
very strong
at first glance Knight to a6 looks a
very good move but in fact it turns out
as a blunder
my next move conform the white victories
I wonder if you can spot it
okay the sequence start with the move
Knight to f6 check and after capture
with the knight here comes Queen to c6
check and after Queen captures Queen and
Bishop captures Queen after the whole
sequence white emerge with an exchange
up
so that was all about Queen to c8 the
second move black and try is the move c6
but here white can capture the D pawn
and black needs to be very very careful
if your opponent can Julie captured with
the C pawn
then there's a trademark trick which
happens in many jobs line that is the
move Queen to a full check and nabbing
the black pressure so you should always
remember this one
after the move he kept his defy white
should capture the b-pawn that forced
the issue with the move Knight to d7 and
once again we reach to another critical
scenario of this opening
here white can capture the see porn but
you should remember this golden rule
that if the C file is open then never
ever capture the second one for example
if white capture the C porn at this
point then after a rope to c8 black is
not only attacking the white queen but
is also threatening a checkmate on the
c1 so more or less white has to give up
the Queen endgame so that's why here the
best move is Knight to c3 and now we all
said to capturing the C pawn I reached
this position in few of my games and all
the time my opponent has responded with
the MU rook to CH that can also play the
Moon Knight to e7 but that was shut down
the effect bishop for a long time so
more frequently look to c8 has been
tried what black is up to is to do a
very fast development and then exploit
the fact that white King is stuck in the
center well here I responded with the
move d4 and after the move Bishop to d6
to my opponent surprise I played a
computer type move Queen captures a7 so
it looks like white is playing like a
beginner's move playing with the Queen
where black is developing is all pieces
and black will emerge with a better
position but this is one of the very
good exception let's see how the game's
turns out so here my opponent obviously
played the move Knight to f6 I responded
with the move Knight to f3 and after he
Castle and I Castle he played the move
rook to e8 I responded with the move
Queen to b6 he attacked my h2 with the
move Queen to c7 where I played the move
h3 and after Bishop to h5 and Queen to
d3
suddenly from nowhere white emerge with
a clear point up and that point is a
distant possible
so sometimes this opening is not about
creating the image Atrix but there are
also some long run tricks also exist
the [ __ ] move blacken tries the Moon
Knight to f6 after this I reckon that I
should capture the D pawn and once again
black response is force black cannot
play the move Knight to d5
because yup of a familiar trick Queen to
f4
after he kept his defy the thought
aggressive move that is Knight to c3 so
all three pieces are raining down to the
d5 square and accordingly black has
tried to lose in the first one one of my
opponent has tried the move Knight to c6
his idea is that if I foolishly capture
the b7 pawn then after night to b4
definitely black is winning but I played
a stronger move that is Knight captures
d5 here there are two moves exist if
your opponent plays the move Knight to
d4 then first of all you should capture
the f6 Knight with the check and after
Queen captures f6 you can cold-bloodedly
capture the b7 pawn
if your opponent plates the obvious
looking move that is night to see to
check then after King 2d one night
captures even you can capture the rook
with a check and after Queen to d8
Bishop to c6 check and King to e7 you
can even capture the a 7-point the
simplest reason is Blackey is clearly
misplaced as well as the night
and at this point white is emerged with
a to pawn up and a better King safety
now instead of night to see to check if
you opponent plays the move rook to D H
then the situation is more worse because
now we can play this Queen to e4 check
not only guarding the c2 but also
attacking the bishop so the bishop has
to go back and after this we play a very
simple move that is III and emerged with
a one-point advantage
so those are the tricks if you opponent
plays the moon night to deform the
obvious move over here is night captures
defy after this we are going to capture
with the bishop so now we are hitting
the f7 square where black has two
choices if you open in place the Moon
Knight to d4 at this Junction then I
recommend that you should play the move
Queen to c4 attacking the knight
attacking the f7 and the same time
defending the seat
the most obvious response is Bishop to
e6
afterwards why should happily capture
this bishop because let's say if your
opponent wants to maintain the integrity
of its pawn structure then it will
definitely capture with the knight but
then white emerge with a clear pawn of
advantage
the most critical trials Queen to d7
which not only defending the f7 square
but creating some nasty tricks for the
white side here comes the owner surprise
that is the MU f3 so he's attacking the
bishop
if black castle on the Queen side then
white is going to capture the g4 and
exchange some pieces where position is
quite okay for white so the most
critical trials Bishop to f5
but now comes the super short that is
Bishop captures f7 BAM
if came to d8 then e4 is a very strong
so the obvious question need to be asked
what will happen a screen captures f7
where after this white can capture the
b7 pawn and this time around not only
white will regain a piece but white will
emerge with a clear to pawn advantage so
the worst converse case is in these
positions what can get at least a draw
so that was about Knight to c6 the
second move blacken tries the move c6
but I don't believe in this line because
here obviously white is going to capture
the b7 pawn and after Knight to d7
remember of our golden rule as here
white has already played the Moon Knight
to c3
that's why white can easily capture the
c6 pawn
yes plaque and get some initiative after
the move look to see it and queen to e4
but already white is upon a head in the
situation and the VAS news is there are
two more pawns are hanging in the black
camp so all in all this is more
enjoyable position for watch the second
move black and try over here is Knight
to f6 but this is one of the easiest
move where white can confirm his
advantage here why should capture the
depot and after black recapture the
simplest move of the game that is going
to be three so attacking the knight
attacking the b7 the worst news for
black is black cannot move the knight so
for example if Knight goes to the b6
then Bishop captures b7 will Nevin
exchange and black also cannot play the
move Essex because our familiar
trademark Queen to f4
so that leads to the only MU left that
is c6 but after this win captures b7 and
after Knight to d7 the golden rule says
that we cannot capture the c6 pawn so we
are going to play the move Knight to c3
Knight is hanging and the pawn on c6
hanging
if black capture the c3 Knight then
after D captures c3 the black pawn is
definitely going to drop and if black
tries to move look to be it then after
Queen captures c6 there are no threats
exist for white for example if your
opponent plays the move Knight to before
then you can easily safeguard the c2
with the move Queen to e4 if Bishop to
a5 then d3 and white is all good the
last move Lacan try is the most c6
well here my recommendation is you
capture the deep own and when black
recaptured with the see porn now you
play the move Queen to b3 so now we have
some nasty threats on d5 as well as b7
and accordingly black has try few
responses
please note that a six is not possible
in this case because of a trademark that
is Queen to b4 check
the first ball I want to consider is the
move Queen to c7 which has a sneaky idea
to checkmate white by capturing the
bishop well of course we are not going
to fall for this so we are going to play
the move Knight to c3 attacking the d5
pawn so accordingly black has tried two
responses if Knight to f6 then the
simplest this Knight captures d5 which
has a merit of attacking Knight as well
as Queen and if black capture this
Knight then after Bishop captures defy
we have familiar trick which we already
seen it
if instead of Knight to f6 black played
the move Knight to c6 then we played the
move Knight to d5 and doesn't matter
whether Queen goes to the sea at od7
square for example in one game my
opponent played the move Queen to CH
then there comes Queen to b3 so now we
are looking at the fork at the c7 the
only good way to defend is to play the
movie Phi but here comes a very little
but the fact you move that is the move
d3 now if your opponent plays Knight to
f6 over here then you can definitely
grab that night and double the black
pawn so accordingly if my opponent
responded over here which many of your
opponent will responded that is the move
Bishop to d6 so idea is to protect that
epon and now black is fattened to move
the knight to the d4 square well it
looks all good and rosy up to my next
move that is the move sv and now black
cannot move the bishop so my opponent
execute his plan with the move Knight to
d4 which at first sight looks very
threatening but after the one that is
Knight to b3 and my opponent resigned
the second new black and try over he is
Knight to f6 but against this I'm
recommending that you should play the
move Queen captures b7 and after Knight
to d7 played the move Knight to c3 so
now three pcs are attacking on d5 so
black responds his force black has to
play the movie six and after this we are
going to play the move d4 now it's true
that this is one of the best try buy the
black but still white can work out some
nasty tricks in this lines to illustrate
them let me show you my best game in
this line so here my opponent responded
with the move Bishop to d6 I responded
with the move Queen to a6 attacking the
bishop and he responded with the move
Queen to c7 so idea is to attack the h2
and quickly going on the kingside castle
after a long thinking I come out
probably one of the best more in the
game that is Bishop to d2 and there are
every chance that your opponent can go
wrong over here for example if black
foolishly Castle at this point then that
comes Knight to be fie and black will
lose a piece so that's not possible if
black plays moves such as Bishop to b4
then he has to watch out for nasty
tricks on the C file after the MOOC to
c1 the third move blacken tries the move
Knight to b6 so blocking the sixth rank
but after this we can play the move
Knight to b5 attacking the two piece and
after Queen to e7 we have a very sneaky
move that is the move a3
can you believe this moves dropping the
castle
if black can select this point then the
simplest is capturing the bishop and
when black we capture we are skewering
queen and a rook so that's why castle is
not possible and let's say black do
another time paths move for example
Bishop to a5 then after this we can
capture this bishop and when black we
capture now we can play the move Bishop
to b4 so hitting the Queen doesn't
matter where the Queen goes for example
if Queen goes to let's say d7 square
then after Knight to f3
it is only white which has many plants
for example Knight to e5 castling rook
to c1 but on the other hand black
doesn't have a concrete plant as his
King is stuck in the center for a long
time and his species are very badly
placed in the game after Bishop to d2 my
opponent immediately capture - - but
this is just asking for it I immediately
responded with the move Knight to be
fire hitting the Queen the only way to
save the bishop is to play Queen to b8
but now comes the obvious move that is
Bishop to b4
stopping back to castle on the kingside
and now my three pieces are looking at
the d6 square after some thinking my
opponent responded with the move Knight
to p6
so blocking the d6 file completely but
here he was stunned by my next move
which was the best more of the game that
his rook captures as - BAM
black has no choice but just to accept
this exchange sacrifice so black played
the MU Queen captures s2 but after Queen
to be seven my opponent has realized the
game is almost lost
so white is threatening a checkmate on
the e7 so black doesn't have time to
capture the knight in the game my
opponent responded with the move Knight
F to d7 I give him this check and after
the force reply King to d8 I captured a
rock in the corner here he was tempted
to capture this night and after the only
good reply that is Bishop to have fun he
played the move Bishop to h3 which at
first sight
looks very very threatening but I have
carefully walk out all this here I
played the winning move of the game that
is Queen to c7 check and after came to D
H Knight captures b6 is a finishing knot
the last mu played by the black is Queen
captures Bishop but after King to d2
unfortunately my opponent has to click
the resign button
I firmly believe now that with this
information you can play this attack
with a very great deal of confidence
feel free to like subscribe and comment
on this video and I'll meet you in my
next lecture with some another fantastic
tricks
until then hunt some fishes with the
Grove attack bye